on the road these cars will put you in
jail as soon as you get in third gear
at Lamborghinis driving school you'll
learn how to drive some of the fastest
cars in the world and I got to check out
a class in a region home to some of the
wealthiest people in America Jason
talked to me first of all about what
we're experiencing here this video is an
opportunity for both prospects and
clients to be able to get a taste of
Lamborghini to be able to get a chance
to experience 700 horsepower all-wheel
drive Aventador which is the flagship of
our family i would say that over the
course of the year we're probably
looking at having anywhere between 4 to
500 people that have a chance to have
this experience which when you think
about it the big picture it's actually
quite a small number but we're talking
about at $500,000 car right so how many
people reach for their wallets on the
way out actually you'd be surprised at
quite a few from the results of these
events we see direct correlations with
the sales that we do Lamborghini only
recently began hosting classes in the
United States America's even more key
because the money's here right now the
biggest sales number one North America
so ironically an Italian brand needs to
sell here like its high-end competitors
Ferrari and Porsche Lamborghini is
trying to turn its clientele into a
sophisticated group of well-groomed
gentlemen racecar drivers and for
enthusiasts who already know their way
around the track Lamborghini has a
fast-paced race series called the super
trofeo to enter all you need is a basic
racing license and a whole lot of cash
how much do you think it would run me if
I wanted to get into super trofeo racing
you're looking from 30 to 45 thousand
dollars a weekend are you gonna time
this of course man three two one go
a nun experience beginner what do I get
one to ten holy on camera yeah nine and
a half nine and a half fail for now my
skill set and my wallet will keep me in
the beginners lame a lot of our
customers are self-made men and this is
a reward or a treat for themselves it's
somebody that has the enthusiasm for the
luxury of life but also is looking for
that performance in that edge
you